well you can never underestimate the
importance of talking to your kids about
internet safety one misjudgment can
haunt a family for a very long time and
what better day than to enforce the
message than today
today is safer internet day a chance for
metro police to speak to schools ptas
and kids directly to impart a crucial
message you need to have this awkward
conversation with your kids because it
could prevent a whole lot of heartache
down the road today an opportunity to
help your child avoid a mistake that can
lead to enduring emotional pain the
message about the downside of sending
inappropriate pictures and sextortion is
one metro imports you to communicate to
your child the most important thing to
say as a parent is just to very simple
terms you know don't ever send pictures
of yourself
unclothed you know so if it's not
covered by a swimsuit it should never be
sent
to anyone else if you wouldn't share it
with your grandmother you probably
shouldn't share it with someone else
online you might be thinking what an
awkward topic to talk about with my kid
if you don't have that awkward
conversation with your kids statistics
show that there's a one in six chance
that they will be victimized online one
in six chants worth overcoming the
awkwardness to help avoid the anguish of
one bad decision and your child might
think they can thoroughly trust their
boyfriend girlfriend or friends
even if you think you can trust the
person that you're sending it to because
it's maybe it's a boyfriend girlfriend
type situation
that doesn't prevent that person from
still sharing it with friends to try to
brag or whatever else and then it going
viral relationships sour just because
you're in love now doesn't mean that
tomorrow they're not going to be mad
because you have a new boyfriend or
girlfriend
and now they're sharing your explicit
content with others and and that can
really destroy children's lives and
there is a wildfire element the scent
picture going far beyond the intended
recipient and then your son or daughter
left to deal with the aftermath the
devastation in their faces and you know
the the tears that i have to see them go
through as they're explaining what
happened
well again it is safer internet day this
is the flyer that metro is using and
they tell us that one in four victims of
sextortion were 13 or younger when
threatened they encourage moms and dads
you are the trusted adult for your son
and daughter have that conversation with
them on what not to do and not to send
on their phone today you want to get
ahead of this problem before it's too
late